>>> MYYE IS WHAT IS DOGECOIN?
>> YOU ASK.
GOOD QUESTION.
IT'S THE FUTURE OF CURRENCY, AN
UNSTOPPABLE FINANCIAL VEHICLE
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE OVER THE
WORLD.
>> I GET THAT.
BUT WHAT IS IT, MAN?
>> I KEEP TELLING YOU IT'S A
CRYPTO-CURRENCY YOU CAN TRADE
FOR CONVENTIONAL MONEY.
>> OH.
SO IT'S A HUSTLE?
>> YEAH, IT'S A HUSTLE.
>> IT'S A HUSTLE.
WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
THAT WAS BILLIONAIRE ELON MUSK
HOSTING "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"
AND STRUGGLING TO EXPLAIN
DOGECOIN, THE LATEST
CRYPTO-CURRENCY CRAZE.
MUSK HAS BEEN A HUGE, HUGE
FACTOR IN THE RISING POPULARITY
OF CRYPTO-CURRENCIES LIKE BIT
COIN.
HIS CAR COMPANY TESLA BOUGHT
ABOUT $1.5 BILLION WORTH OF BIT
COIN EARLIER THIS YEAR.
YESTERDAY, HE SENT THE VALUE OF
BIT COIN PLUNGING WITH AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT TESLA WILL
STOP ACCEPTING THE
CRYPTO-CURRENCY IN PAYMENT FOR
CARS.
IN A STATEMENT, MUSK POINTED TO
THE INCREASING USE OF FOSSIL
FUELS FOR BITCOIN MINING AND
TRANSACTIONS.
HE SAID, "THE USE OF BITCOIN
CANNOT COME AT GREAT COST TO THE
ENVIRONMENT."
THE ENVIRONMENT, YOU SAY.
>> YEAH.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN.
>> I'M CONFUSED.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS A TANGIBLE
THING.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT, IT'S NOT A
TANGIBLE THING.
LET ME EXPLAIN HOW THIS IS
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE ANSWER IS COMPUTERS.
LOTS OF THEM.
BACK IN 2018, OUR ERROLL BARNETT
TRAVELED TO WASHINGTON STATE
VISITING ONE OF THOSE BITCOIN
FARMS WHERE THE TRANSACTIONS
TAKE PLACE.
HERE'S IS PART OF HIS REPORT.
>> LOOKS LIKE A HAND DRYER.
>> YEAH.
EVERY ONE OF THESE THINGS IS
LIKE 1,000-WATT HAIR DRYER.
THERE WILL BE 1,000 OF THOSE IN
THIS POD --
>> Reporter: THESE FANS ARE
OPERATING 24/7 TO COOL ENDLESS
ROWS OF COMPUTER SERVERS.
EACH ONE FEVERISHLY WORKING TO
MINE CRYPTO-CURRENCY.
THIS IS HOW DIGITAL CURRENCY IS
MADE.
EVERY TIME SOMEONE USES
CRYPTO-CURRENCY TO PAY FOR
SOMETHING, IT SETS OFF A FLURRY
OF ACTIVITY.
SERVERS LIKE THESE WORK TO
VERIFY AND PROCESS THAT
TRANSACTION.
EACH ONE RACING TO AUTHENTICATE
THE EXCHANGE OF DIGITAL MONEY
THROUGH COMPLEX CALCULATIONS.
FOR DOING THIS WORK, THE
MACHINES ARE REWARDED WITH NEW
CRYPTO-CURRENCY.
THIS IS WHAT'S CALLED MINING.
>> THE OUTLETS, YOU SEE HOW MUCH
POWER THIS FACILITY USES
COMPARED TO LIKE A TYPICAL
BUILDING?
>> SO OUR PODS USE 1.5
MEGAWATTS.
THAT'S TYPICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
LIKE 600 HOMES.
>> Reporter: SO JUST THIS ONE
FACILITY HAS THIS MUCH ENERGY
LIKE 600 HOMES --
>> 600.
>> RIGHT HERE IN THIS SPACE?
I MEAN, THAT'S -- THAT'S
INCREDIBLE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET ME DO -- LET ME DO MY JOHN
McLACHLAN QUESTION.
THE VALUE OF BITCOIN WAS $6,500
WHEN ERROL DID THE REPORT IN
2018.
WHAT IS THE VALUE TODAY?
>> IT'S A LOT MORE.
>> IT HAS JUMPED -- GET THIS --
TO $56,000 TODAY.
>> WOW.
>> $6,500 TO 56,000.
600 HOMES, THAT WAS THREE YEARS
AGO.
BITCOIN HAS EXPLODED IN VALUE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CAMBRIDGE
ESTIMATES THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY USED WORLDWIDE BY
BITCOIN MINERS IS MORE THAN ALL
OF SWEDEN OR MALAYSIA USES.
AND WITH ITS VALUE CONTINUED TO
GROW, A STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF HAWAII WARNS THAT
IF THIS CONTINUES BITCOIN ALONE
COULD RAISE THE EARTH'S AVERAGE
TEMPERATURE ANOTHER TWO DEGREES
IN THE NEXT 20 YEARS.
LET THAT SINK IN.
>> THAT MEANS THEY'LL NEED A LOT
MORE OF THOSE MACHINES --
>> MORE SERVER SPACE.
>> YES.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE -- THAT'S WHAT
WE DON'T WANT.
IT'S SO CONFUSING.
IT'S NEVER GOOD WHEN THEY SAY
IT'S SUCKING UP X FILL IN THE
BLANK WHICH IS WHAT ERROL AND
THE GENTLEMAN JUST SAID.
NOW BITCOIN IS NOT GOOD.
>> WELL, IT'S CLEARLY GOING TO
DAMAGE THE ENVIRONMENT.
YEAH.
EVEN AS